we've already explored a two-dimensional
version of the divergence theorem if i
have some region so this is my region
right over here right over here we'll
call it r and let's call the boundary of
my region let's call that c and if i
have some vector field in this region so
let me draw a vector field like this
if i draw
a vector field
just like that our two dimensional
divergence theorem which we really
derived from green's theorem
told us that
the
the flux across our boundary of this
region so let me write that out the flux
across the boundary so the flux is
essentially going to be the vector field
is going to be our vector field f
dotted with the normal outward facing
vector so the normal vector at any point
is this outward facing vector so our
vector field dotted with the normal
facing vector add our at our boundary
times our little chunk of the boundary
times our little chunk
times our little chunk of the boundary
if we were to sum them all up over the
entire boundary if we were summed them
up we write a little bit neater if we
were to sum them all up over the entire
boundary that's the same thing as
summing up over the entire region so
let's sum up over the entire region so
summing up over this entire region each
little chunk of area each little chunk
of area
d a we could call that d x d y if we
wanted to if we're dealing in the x y
domain right over here
but each little chunk of area times the
divergence of f which is really saying
how much of that is that vector field
pulling apart so it's times
the divergence
times the divergence of f and hopefully
it made intuitive sense the way that i
drew this vector field right over here
you see everything's kind of coming out
you could almost call this a source
right here where the vector field seems
like it's popping out of there this has
positive divergence right over here and
so because of this you actually see that
the vector field at the boundary is
actually going in the direction of the
normal vector pretty close to the
direction of the normal vector so it
makes sense you have positive divergence
and this is going to be a positive value
the vector field is going for the most
part in the direction of the normal
vector so as the larger this is the
larger that is so hopefully some
intuitive sense if you had another if
you had another vector field if you had
another vector field so let me draw
another region that looked like this so
i could draw a couple of situations so
one where there's very limited
divergence maybe it's just a constant
vector the vector field doesn't really
change as you go
as you go in any
given direction over here you'll get
positive fluxes i don't know what the
plural of flux is you'll get positive
fluxes because the vector field seems to
be going in direction in roughly the
same direction as our normal vector but
here you'll get a negative flux so stuff
is coming in here if you imagine your
vector field is essentially some type of
mass density times volume and we've
thought about that before
this is showing how much stuff is coming
in and then stuff is coming out so your
net flux will or your net flux will be
close to zero stuff is coming in and
stuff is coming out here you're just
saying hey stuff is constantly coming
out of this surface so hopefully this
gives you a sense that here you have
very low divergence and you have would
have a low flux total aggregate flux
going through your boundary here you
have a high divergence and you would
have a high aggregate flux i could draw
another situation
so this is my
region r and let's say that we have
negative divergence or we could even
call it convergence convergence is an
actual technical term but you can
imagine if the vector field is
converging
is converging within r
within r well the divergence is going to
be negative in this situation it's
actually converging which is the
opposite of diverging so the divergence
is negative in this situation and also
the flux across the boundary is going to
be negative because as we see here the
way i drew it across most of this
boundary the vector field is going in
the opposite direction it's going in the
opposite direction as our normal vector
at any point so hopefully this gives you
a sense of why there's this connection
between the divergence over the region
and the flux across the boundary well
now we're just going to extend this to
three dimensions and it's the exact same
reasoning
if we have a and i'll define it a little
bit more precisely in future videos
a simple solid region
so let me just draw and i'm going to try
to draw it in three dimensions so let's
say it looks something like
that and one way to think about it is
this is going to be a region that
doesn't bend back on itself and if you
have a region that bends back on itself
well we'll think about in multiple ways
but out of all of the the volumes of
three dimensions that you can imagine
these are the ones that don't bend back
on themselves and and there are some
that you might not be able to imagine
that would also not make the case but
even if you had ones that bended back or
that bent back on themselves you could
you could separate them out into other
ones that don't so here's just a simple
a simple solid region over here i'll
make it look three-dimensional so maybe
if you could see if it was transparent
you would see it like that and then you
see the front the front of it like that
so it's this kind of elliptical circular
blob looking thing so that could be the
back of it and then if you go to the
front it could be like it could look
something like that so this is our
simple
this is our simple solid region i'll
call it i'll call it well i'll call it r
still but we're dealing with a three
dimensional we are now dealing with a
three-dimensional
region
and now the boundary of this is no
longer a line we're now in three
dimensions the boundary is a surface so
i'll call that s
s is
s is the boundary
boundary
of r and now let's throw on a vector
field here now this is a vector field in
three dimensions and now let's imagine
that we actually have positive
positive divergence of our vector field
within this region right over here
so we have positive divergence so you
can imagine that it's kind of the vector
field within the region
it's kind of it's a source of the vector
field or the vector field is diverging
out of
the vector field is diverging out that's
just the case i drew right over here and
the other thing we want to say about
vector field s it's oriented in a way
that its normal vector is outward facing
so outward
outward
normal vector so the normal it's
oriented so that the surface the normal
vector is like that the other option is
that you have an inward facing normal
vector but we're assuming it's an
outward facing n well then we just
extrapolate this to three dimensions we
essentially say the flux across the
surface
so the flux across the surface you would
take your vector field
you would take your vector field dot it
with the normal vector at the surface
dot it with the normal vector at the
surface and then multiply that times a
little chunk of surface
so multiply that times a little chunk of
surface and then sum it up along the
whole surface so sum it up so it's going
to be a surface integral so this is flux
across the surface
flux
across
across
the surface is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to if we were to
sum up the divergence of f
if we were to sum up across the whole
volume so now if we're summing up things
on every every little chunk of volume
over here in three dimensions we're
gonna have to take integrals along each
dimension so it's going to be a triple
integral so it's going to be a triple
integral
over the region
of the divergence of f so we're going to
say how much is f what is the divergence
at f at each point and then multiply it
times the volume of that little chunk
and multiply it times the volume of that
chunk a sense of how much is it totally
diverging in that volume
and then you sum it up that should be
equal to the flux it's completely
analogous to what here here we had a
flux across
across the line we had essentially a two
dimensional or i guess we could say it's
a one-dimensional boundary so flux
flux across
across the curve
and here we have the flux across the
surface here we were summing the
divergent in the region here we're
summing it in the volume but it's the
exact same logic if you had a vector
field like this that was fairly constant
going through the surface on one side
you would have a negative flux on the
other side you would have a positive
flux and they would roughly cancel out
and that makes sense because there would
be no diverging going on if you had a
converging vector field where it's
coming in the flux would be negative
because it's going in the opposite
direction of the normal vector and so
the divergence the divergence would be
negative as well because essentially the
vector field would be converging so
hopefully this gives you a an intuition
of what the diver that the divergence
theorem is actually saying something
very very very very almost common sense
or intuitive
and now in the next few videos we can do
some work examples just so you feel
comfortable computing or manipulating
these integrals and then we'll do a
couple of proof videos where we actually
prove the divergence theorem